[Music]
started as an idea what if we made a
Deadpool movie there's only a few of us
back then and looking back we had no
idea how big it would become so innocent
and yet the momentum that had started
Yetta was not really what we had in mind
well that didn't help things
it was more of a hell no to be honest to
me we eventually stopped asking we have
no idea how that happened but I promise
you I'm looking into it well what's the
movie got greenlit I went on a massive
coke bender
so 2016 that's a little hazy for me they
tell me the movie did well though ten
years into it phase one has exceeded our
wildest expectations you know if you
told me back then that one movie would
spawn an expansive two movie universe
I'd have said that you were crazy
but here we are with actual actors a
moderate special effects budget and
several low-level x-men none of the big
ones though we got to save something for
phase 2 bristly this Friday
the most unique and refreshing franchise
of all time
all right who ordered the stripper
critics around the world love Deadpool
to Rolling Stone says it's irresistible
and Richard Roeper of the Chicago
sun-times calls it the best sequel since
Godfather Part 2 nice well maybe not but
it's still great that's just lazy
writing Deadpool - hello friends there
are three things in life you should
never skip breakfast your heart
medication and Deadpool -
first off me dominoe what's your power
I'm lucky luck isn't a superpower
you're hired
four or five moments that's all it takes
to be a hero
try again you're right you're the music
doing the right thing is messy but if
you want to fight for what's right
sometimes you have to fight dirty don't
you not knock I thought you saw me with
your ears get tickets now hello
Deadpool here reminding you that there
are three things in life you should
never skip breakfast your heart
medication and this ad for my new movie
hello friends beautiful things I've ever
heard I want some water
daddy's got this has to be fun
it's show time avenge tickets on sale
now
you